c'est une guerre de succession qui ne
dit pas vraiment son nom mais à chevigny
saint sauveur c'est bien l'héritage de
lucien brenot qui est en jeu maire
pendant près de 30 ans de la commune il
est décédé en octobre 2012
et c'est son premier adjoint michel
rodde g qui lui a succédé à son bureau
investi par l'ump soutenu par l'ue dit
ils revendiquent un héritage naturel
c'était le souhait de lucien brenot
quelques semaines avant son décès il m'a
dit michel tu reprendras la liste comme
il avait d'ailleurs en 1904 en 1987 dans
une réunion au polygone un dimanche
après midi
et donc j'ai suivi naturellement le
souhait du cerveau qui était là non le
serai naturellement de tous mes
collègues du conseil municipal
loin d'être sa majorité mais un autre
candidat revendique aussi l'héritage en
ferrain longtemps premier adjoint mais
absent de la dernière mandature
le président de l'ump y refuse toute
étiquette politique même s'il penche à
droite avec la présence dans sa liste de
pascal karras telle est également de la
femme de lucien brenot
il ya eu un maire qui a bâti chevigny
qui est lucien brenot
il a dit que pour le remplacer après son
décès c'est est le suivant liste il a
dit le seul qui est capable de gérer la
commune c'est jean perras on a été
ensemble pendant 25 ans jeté son premier
adjoint
j'ai été son collaborateur parlementaire
quand il était député il me connaissait
bien il me connaît bien et je veux dire
tout le monde a adhéré à cette idée
et donc il n'y a pas de succession il ya
et bien plus il ya surtout un projet à
faire et à bâtir dans ce contexte de
division le candidat de la gauche louis
legrand qui avait obtenu 42 % des voix
en 2008 nourrit beaucoup d'espoirs dans
une ville qui est resté à quai du
tramway et qui avait placé françois
hollande en tête à la présidentielle
il propose une liste de large
rassemblement et compte surfer sur ses
liens privilégiés avec l'agglomération
dijonnaise
ce qui va beaucoup compter puisque c'est
une élection locale
c'est la situation locale on est dans
une agglomération qui est très bien
gérée on est à côté d'une très grande
ville dijon qui a un rayonnement que
dijon n'a jamais connu de lui que
rebsamen et mer dijon est connu et un
rayonnement très important je pense
qu'on va plus bénéficié de cet élan
plutôt que de dieu du contexte national
alors la droite peut-elle perdre ce
bastion reste une grande inconnue dans
ce scrutin
les nouveaux électeurs car chevigny a
beaucoup poussé en trente ans elle a
multiplié par 4 sa population